at Montclair book centre rows of every
book imaginable from the new title just
published to the dusty and obscure old
book if you look hard enough you'll
probably find it here what you won't
find is customers browsing the aisles in
March
all non-essential businesses were closed
because of coronavirus the bookstore
staff faced hard decisions closed down
after 35 years in business or find a way
to keep selling nobody wanted to close
we just had to figure out the best way
to keep everybody safe and healthy while
also continuing to serve they ramped up
taking orders by phone and also online
sales and business has been so good
nobody has been laid off everybody in
fact is busy in a normal week when it
was when we were open we'd maybe have 10
internet or 10 online orders a day but
now we come in and we have at least 50
if we have anything under the under 50
that's it that's a light day for us at
this point by the front door stacks of
packages of books waiting to be shipped
out to customers a small sign of a
success story in an economy where there
have been few when many people think
about business in America they think of
big companies such as General Motors
Apple or maybe even Walmart but truth be
told more than 95% of Americans work at
small businesses like this defined as
those with less than 500 employees it's
small business that is the backbone of
the American economy that's small
business that has been decimated by
coronavirus Montclair bookstore sits in
the middle of two other stores going
through much harder times on one side a
hair salon that remains closed on the
other side a gift shop also shuttered
but in between one store that has made
it writing its own story of success
Gabriel Sandow al Jazeera Montclair New
Jersey